un disneyland du politiquement correct
ce sont les mots d'un architecte
parisien pour décrire les projets de
rénovation de la cathédrale notre dame
de paris maurice culot c'est son nom
s'est confié dans les colonnes du
quotidien britannique the telegraph ce
qu'il propose de faire ne se serait
jamais produit à l'abbaye de westminster
où à saint pierre de rome c'est une
sorte de parc à thème très enfantin et
trivial étant donnée la grandeur du lieu
ils sont ainsi plusieurs a dénoncé des
rénovations qui je cite mutile ray
l'édifice des informations démenties par
le diocèse à nos confrères de la fp sans
pour autant donner plus de précisions
sur le réaménagement du bâtiment notez
qu'au mois de juillet dernier chez une
plainte a été déposée contre x pour mise
en danger de la vie d'autrui l'incendié
qui a ravagé la cathédrale a entraîné
une pollution au plomb la cgt paris des
associations et des riverains reprochent
aux autorités publiques de ne pas avoir
communiqué sur cette pollution dans la
zone du bâtiment zones où se situent des
écoles et des crèches ce sont plus de
400 tonnes de plomb qui ont été
détruites au cours de cet incendie ou en
partie fondu ou ont été pulvérisés en
microparticules qui se sont disséminés
dans l'atmosphère en dépit de l'ampleur
de l'incendié de la connaissance des
risques de pollution mais de
contamination aucune précaution
particulière n'a été prise par les
autorités concernées ministère de la
culture agences régionales de santé
préfecture de police pendant plus de
trois mois après l incendie du côté de
l' enquête elle est toujours en cours en
juin 2019 à l'issue de l'enquêté
préliminaire la piste accidentelle était
privilégiée par le procureur de paris en
attendant selon le calendrier des
travaux l'édifice devrait rouvrir au
public courant 2024